DAVID THORBURN: I've thought
a lot about what it means
to lecture to undergraduates.
One of the reasons I
thought a lot about it
was that the most inspiring
teachers I had as a student
were lecturers.
And as I become-- Both
at Yale and at MIT
I taught lecture courses.
And I became, I
think, good at them.
But I was never as
good as I wanted to be.
And I think maybe one thing that
made me a good lecturer was I
was always nervous.
And even to this day, I've been
lecturing in the film course
now I think 38 or 39 years.
I still get stage fright.
But I'm glad I do it because it
makes me live for the students.
I hated bad lectures.
I thought they were the
pits of higher education.
And I swore to myself that
if I became a lecturer
I would never bore my students.
That was a worse sin
then almost any other
a teacher could commit
was to be boring.
And I have also felt
that, in recent years
especially, although
it's always been
an undercurrent in
education, there's
been a kind of growing
negative feeling
about lectures as if
they're herding students
into our herd experience.
And it doesn't give them
hands on experience.
And I think, intellectually,
that's a foolish perspective.
Professors no more
than students.
It's appropriate for students to
listen to professors sometime.
Professors should take
the responsibility
of when they talk to
students very seriously.
If they can present
the information
to students in ways that
are more effective on paper,
or on film, or in some other
format, on video disks,
or on computer disks
they should do so.
But if they take-- And
in a small classroom
they should certainly encourage
discussion and interaction.
But I think surely there are
times and places, especially
in the humanities,
when it's perfectly
appropriate for a professor who
knows an immense amount more
than the students to
present material that
has been synthesized
by the years of study
and understanding
that he or she has.
And the greatest experiences,
the most inspiring intellectual
experiences I had as an
undergraduate in college
were from lecturers.
And I taught-- I
was very fortunate.
I went to a
wonderful university.
Princeton.
They had very small classes.
I was in some
tutorials that, they
were called preceptorials,
that were seven
students and a full professor.
So I got the benefits of intense
one on one or close to one
on one attention.
And I loved those classes.
But the classes I had in
which they were 100 or 75
or 150 students listening
to a Professor of History,
or a Professor of Philosophy, or
a Professor of Literature talk
in the ways they did about
ideas, about the history
of ideas, about
the power of texts,
taught me what literature
is and taught me
what intellectual engagement
with literature should be.
And I swore to myself
that if I became a teacher
I would try to be a good
lecturer rather than a bad one.
So it seemed to me
as-- First of all,
as I thought about the
most inspiring lectures
that I had as an undergraduate.
It was one professor
I had especially.
He's now dead.
But he was a wonderfully
inspiring man.
Also became an
inspiring scholar who
didn't produce a lot of
work but his scholarship
was very productive.
And he was a department
chair who generated
a lot of colleagues work.
He was a great man.
His name was Lawrence Holland.
His book was called,
it was on Henry James,
it was called The
Expense of Spirit.
his lecture was on
American literature.
And a number of
us in that course
became Professors of Literature.
I'm thinking now who
I've state in touch with
and they're also teaching
or still teaching
around the country.
So Holland affected other
students as well as me.
And his strategy in
lectures I've tried to copy.
Or even plagiarize.
One thing he always did was
he presented an outline.
It was not the text
of the lecture.
But it was three or four
central digestible points
that organized the
lecture in sequence.
He would give out mimeographed
sheet to each of his students
and you would follow along.
And sometimes under
each rubric there
might be one or two other sub
facts to help the student.
It didn't capture
the whole lecture.
But you could use that sheet
to organize your understanding
of the lecture.
I thought that was a
wonderfully helpful.
I found it wonderfully helpful.
Both for review.
But also because
what it showed me
was that Professor Holland
had planned what he was doing.
That he was presenting
material to me
that he had thought
long about that
he organized in a serious way.
But the second great thing
about Larry Holland's lectures
was that they were not
completely written out.
There were parts of them
that were written out.
Very eloquent moments often
at the beginning at the end.
And I've sometimes
imitated that.
But the greatest
part of his lectures
were his lectures
seemed spontaneous.
Even though he was
following his lecture
it seemed as if he was not.
He was speaking to me.
And I tried to capture.
I've never been
as good as he was.
Another professor who did
this, but who read his lectures
and was theatrically
very powerful,
taught with me at Yale.
And it was Bart Giamatti
the man who became
the President of Baseball.
First the President
of the American League
and then the
Commissioner of Baseball.
And he was a great teacher, too.
And a great lecturer.
But he wrote most of his out.
And he used to
practice his readings.
And I felt, even though
his lectures were great,
that they didn't match
what Holland did,
my undergraduate mentor,
because Holland seemed really
to be talking to me.
And yet when I, as a student,
looked at his outline
I realized that he'd given
me a brilliantly coherent--
That was my ideal.
I'm not sure I actually fully
ever realized the ideal.
And that may be part of the cost
you pay for not writing it out.
Because what has
happened-- I mean,
I always give an
outline to my students.
And I try to follow the outline.
But I also try to
leave-- and I also plan
and I pick my details.
When I'm lecturing
in the film course
I create clips that I show
that I've sort of planned
when I want to use the clips.
And they interrupt the
flow of my discourse.
So this first sequence,
it comes from Cops.
And in many ways I
think it embodies that,
kind of, a version
of the trajectory ,
or crescendo joke I was
talking about earlier.
It's a small version
of the cannon joke
that you see in,
or jokes plural,
because there's another
joke with a cannon
in the second half of the film
that I've talked about earlier.
Let's show it Greg.
And of course this is
the moment where Keaton
is in flight from the police.
The cops are chasing him.
He runs up this
teeter totter, right?
He runs up a ladder it turns
out to be like a seesaw.
But when I am at
my best I think I'm
doing something that can't
be captured in printed form.
Or couldn't be captured
if you gave students
a transcript of
what you had done.
Which is that I'm
modeling thinking.
I'm modeling how you
make connections.
I'm even modeling
discovery in a certain way.
Intellectual discovery.
Because by not actually
writing the words out
I sometimes bring the material
together in a different way.
And I do make discoveries
while I'm talking.
And that energizes me and
makes me more powerful.
And I think that
was another thing
that I got from Larry Holland.
I realized that another aspect
of what he was showing me
was how not just
intellectually engaged
but how passionately engaged,
how emotionally valuable
studying literature could be.
And I tried in my lectures,
not exactly consciously
because I think I absorbed
some of this unconscious.
Only in recent years that I've
thought about it abstractly
and I'm able to articulate it.
But I see now that
Lawrence Holland
was a great-- I had other
great lecturers at Princeton.
He wasn't the only one.
But Holland was the one I
remember best and I admire
and I sometimes,
when I remember to do
this in the last lecture
of the film course,
I pay respects to him.
I'm getting
sentimental about him.
I haven't seen him or talked
to him in 30, 40 years.
In a certain sense
that what I try
to tell the students about
what I do for the film courses
is this.
I want them to watch-- the
movie is the primary text.
And I see myself, in
some sense, as playing
the role of a kind of
synthesizer or channel,
which tries to give a kind
of brief but extraordinarily
concise account or summary of
the best that has been said
about this particular film.
Or the best that has been said
about the historical processes
that lead up to the
making of the film.
In other words, because I
don't expect my students
to become film scholars
or literary scholars.
In my literature courses
I have the same ambition.
I imagine that the kind
of student I want to reach
is that of a literate citizen.
And I don't expect them to
have the kind of knowledge
that a scholar what have.
I try to play the role of
someone who synthesizes aspects
of the scholarship for them.
And that's also another
reason why the lecture
is what is important.
Because I could
have the students
read five scholarly books
and synthesize them.
But I do that for
them so that they
have the time to
look at the film
and think about it seriously.
The environment of the
classroom or the lecture room
is a unique kind of community.
It depends on certain
kinds of conventions
that everyone accepts.
For example.
In the lecture students
know they're not
supposed to raise
and interrupt you
in the middle of your lecture.
And it's only a very
aggressive or arrogant student
who will do so.
A good lecturer
will sometimes say,
if you have questions
I'll make time at the end.
Or in my classes what I
try to do is say, look.
I'm going to give the first
15 minutes of my lecture
next week to questions you
might have about anything.
And I urge you to bring them up.
You need to do that, I
think, if you're lecturing.
You shouldn't ever-- In
my courses, of course,
there's also, and I
think is critical.
I don't believe in courses
that are only lecture.
Even my course, which has
two hours of lecture a week,
has one hour of discussion.
Recitation.
I think it's very
important for the students
to take possession of the
ideas that you talk about.
I think that students
in a good class,
I think you do create a kind
of community of learning.
A community of inquiry.
It can be especially exciting
in a discussion class
where you actually talk
about-- I try to tell students,
you know, this is one of
the few places in which you
can get angry in a certain way.
And passionate in
disagreement with someone
and not offend them.
And that's the most exciting
kind of class when you say,
you know, you're completely
wrong about that passage.
Knowing that the person
you're saying that to
won't be offended.
You're not attacking the person.
You're part of the
passionate discourse
of trying to understand
the excitement of trying
to understand the text.
Trying to understand what's
some writer or artist has done.
That can be so enlivening.
And it can be truly a
deeply communal experience.
It doesn't even work if it's
not, in some sense, communal.
So I think even in a lecture
there's a sense of interaction
between you and your audience.
And if your audience is
bored, if your audience
is not listening,
if they go online
and start doing their homework.
Right?
Or their email.
You're a bad teacher and
you shouldn't be doing it.
If you're arrogant
enough to think
that you want the
students to pay attention
to you for 50 minutes
without interruption
you better be organized
and you better be good.
And I think a lot of
professors are not.
And I think that they
dishonor my profession
when they do that.
I think we shouldn't have
lecturers who don't really
do their job properly.
But I think lecturers who do,
do a uniquely valuable job.
They model things for students
that they can't get themselves
in discussion.
They show what real
learning can be.
And what passionate engagement
with learning can also be.
And that's the kind
of defense I would
give of the medium
of the live lecture.